Priscilla is with us in Orlando hi
Priscilla how are you my name it's an
honor to speak to you thank you so much
for taking my call
absolutely how can I help alright so I'm
a bit conflicted right now and I kind of
look like your wisdom on this I've been
getting a really strong Christian man
for about seven months and engagement is
kind of on the table
but my confession is his financial
status and I don't know if I'm being a
little too critical about the situation
or should I concentrate you on a
spiritual walk and then I don't know so
basically I'm a double what he makes and
I'm almost on a debt I'm about to pay my
calls and I just have my student loan
left what do you mean what do you make I
make take-home monthly is a little over
4,000 and he is that guy so you're
making like you're making like $65,000 a
year and he's making like 30 yeah okay
and what do you doing radiation
therapist what does he do he a biller he
works in an accounting department yeah
kind of and he just fill jobs for a
company okay and how old is he he's 36
and how old are you when I'm 32
okay so your question is it is your
question is what then I'm just I don't
know if I'm concentrating I feel like
it's really his financial status I'm
concentrating too much on it and I'm
really hardcore and what you believe in
what you do and I've been through a few
and so I've been trying to talk to him
and like maybe get better jobs and like
very content and very comfortable and I
don't know if there's big huge red flag
and you know that's why she's got 65,000
and a student loan and 12,000 and car
and I will have about 12,000 lost again
so what you're telling me is is
I I disagree with your analysis that
you're worried about the financial
status I think you're worried about his
lack of ambition mm-hmm yeah that teal
is a red flag - and because if he was
making this if he was making this but he
was a go-getter and he was willing to
grind and hustle and he had like 17
plans for to better himself and he was
going to be diligent and he was going to
be excellent and he was going to go into
the marketplace and you know provide for
his family and you know scratching claw
you wouldn't care if he was making 30
yeah it's a fact that you think he's
probably going to be making thirty ten
years from now and 20 years from now
because he really just doesn't give a
real and and he's content and I think
it's a spiritual log I'm content
contentment and ambition are not on the
same spectrum well in terms of spiritual
contentment okay you can be spiritually
a content person and yet still be
striving for excellence and diligence
mm-hmm I still have an ambition and
still have initiative and those kinds of
things and so I'm gonna give you a
little more credit because you you kind
of set this up like you're a snob and I
don't think you're a snob I think you're
worried about not his money but you're
worried about his ambition and his
initiative yeah our family like if I
were to get married to him so I just I'm
so paranoid when it comes to funds and
financial status and I worked so hard to
where I've got gotten and I just I'm
just so nervous well I'm not I would not
I would not walk away from someone based
on financial status mm-hmm or whatever
but but I would walk away from someone
if you don't think they are going you
know if you don't think he's got enough
ambition to pull himself up and go do
something else over time and that that
bothers me as a dad of a 31 year old
daughter if one of my son in-laws fell
in that category I would be I'd be
worried about my daughter yeah you know
parents are they are and so and it's not
that they
he's a bad person or that is that he
doesn't love Jesus that's not the point
the point is is that his faith has not
caused him to move towards diligence and
to move towards excellence in his life
and to be all that God has created him
to be he's willing to just sit there and
do that one thing and that'd make him a
bad guy it just may make him a not a fit
for you I can tell you he wouldn't fit
in the Ramsey family if he's not gonna
better himself
mm-hmm and I don't really care what he
makes I just want to see that he's
willing to do something and hustle but
you know take it easy
I don't want working extra hours I'm
gonna uh you know oh no I wouldn't take
overtime
oh you know I'm sitting on $60,000 in
student loan debt in a car dad and he's
just kind of coasting that bothers me
that bothers me so I'm with your mom and
dad on that I'm not trying to break you
up but but what what would I do if I
were how would I coach you if this was
my daughter I would if I would
engagements on the table I would sit
down with a young man and go dude this
isn't gonna work because my daughter's
gonna kill you if you don't if you don't
decide to have some career goals and to
decide to do something with your life
your this is not gonna be a fit for you
guys and so if your dad's not gonna do
that you probably need to do it and you
just need to say I you know I really do
care about you I really do want to move
forward but I can't I'm not gonna be
okay with you still make you doing
nothing to better your life mm-hmm
and I'm just not wired that way and
again it doesn't it doesn't make him a
bad guy doesn't make you a bet it
doesn't make you a financial snob hmm it
just says you're different and you know
you're gonna be nagging him for the next
22 years is how it's gonna feel if he
doesn't now he may say hey there's a
side of me that I you know in seven
months of dating I'm not really shown
you but here's some things I'm thinking
about and you're right I do need to do
that as an act of my faith I need act my
faith out in the market
place in a way that's you know diligent
because the diligent prosper that's in
the Bible you know and so it's not a you
know you're not a bad spiritual person
if you serve with excellence and scratch
and claw and go win in the marketplace
because that's biblical work is biblical
and so you know doing the minimum amount
of work and you know just hanging out is
you know I know that's not gonna fit you
and you know how I know it's not gonna
fit you because you called me to ask me
about it mm-hmm so it's bothering the
crud out of you yeah I don't go forward
with this engagement until you guys
solve this because if it's not solved
it's a deal breaker if you still have
the same perception of him now maybe you
maybe that maybe you learn something
about him or he says hey you know behind
every great man is a better woman and
you know I'm willing to do some stuff to
keep you in my life and and you know
that kind of thing and I just need your
the spark I needed under my butt to get
me up and moving you know he made that
maybe the reaction and it could be a
very positive reaction and this could
all go forward and be wonderful but if
he just says you know no I really don't
want anybody bothering me about kind of
better myself or you know move up in my
career or I don't by bothering me about
that I'm just content where I am and you
got to go I'm not gonna be and it's a
deal breaker because it's so different
than your value system and that's why
your mom and dad are worried about it I
think it's a valid worry you may want to
sit down a good marriage counselor and
they look pretty engagement counseling
wouldn't hurt a couple hundred bucks
spent there might save you a lifetime of
pain
this is the dev Ramsay show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]